جديد مباشره الى هذه الصور التي تردنا
مباشره للرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد
ترامب فيف بالم بيتش في فلوريدا همم حيث
ادلى بصوته همم منذ قليل حسب ما يقال لي
بالطباعه هو
وهممته رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالطبع البعض يرى في هذه الانتخابات بانها
استفتاء حقيقي ومباشر على شعبيات الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب من اجل عوده قويه في
انتخابات 20 همم 24
ساحاول ان اسال ضيوفي بعد قليل همم عن همم
هذه همم المساله ولكن همم نبقى مع هذه
الصور همم بالصوت
وماذا سيقول الرئيس دونالد ترامب
فضل الوالدين
[موسيقى]
على ذلك بسرعه
لان الاعدادات اكبر تدفق الى بلادنا وبنات
تدمر فهذا سيحصل
ولكن يجب ان نحارب الجريمه وانخفض ضرائب
ويجب ان افعل اشياء نحيه على الحدود ويجب
لكم كل ذلك الى الانثي
ين
شكرا لكم جميعا
بالطبع الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب وزوجته ميلانيا ترامب بعد ادلائه
بصوته همم
فلوريدا ابرز ما قاله في اجابه على بعض
اسئله الصحفيين على الامريكيين الخروج
والتصويت بقوه الان سنخفض الضرائب في حين
ان الديمقراطيين يرغبون برفعها يجب ان
نفعل شيئا حيال حدودنا ومساله المهاجرين
واا يعني الحديث الساعه الان عن سيكون
هنالك من مفاجات يوم الثلاثاء القادم لبعض
بالطبع همم يتوقع همم الجميع همم او معظم
المراقبين بان يعلن يوم الثلاثاء القادم
الرئيس السابق ترامب ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه 20 24 ولكن حتى الساعه يعني همم
ردوا على السؤال قال يوم الثلاثاء القادم
سيكون مشوقا للجميع يعني تجنب التاكيد
مباشره همم حول هذه المساله ما اذا كان
سيترشح ام لا قال يوم الثلاثاء القادم
سيكون مشوقا لل الجميع